امسك اعلن انه راح يطلق الشكل الجديد
لميزه التوثيق يوم الجمعه والي راح تعتمد
الالوان الذهبي للحكومات والرمادي للشركات
والازرق للافراد مشاهير او مشاهير وكلنا
نعرف الجذر اللي سببتوا اصلا الحله الجديد
للتوثيق من وقت ما اعلنسك انه راح يفض
رسوم على هذه الحسابات 800$ شهريا بمناسبه
الكلام عن التوفيق هذا واللي معصب كثير
ناس امس امس كشف انه هو راح يدفع الرسوم
مثله مثل اي مشترك موثق حسابه على تويتر
يعني بيقول لي المعترضين ترى انا مثلي
مثلكم كوني مالك ورئيس توتير ما راح
يعرفني من الثمانيه دولارات وقبل هذه
التغريده قال الماس كان غرد كمان داعيا
الناس الاستخدام تويتر منصه للنقاش وقال
انه بيشجع الكل على الدخول في نقاشات
حضاريه على تويتر مع المختلفين سياسيا
معهم في الاراء وانه اسوء شيء ممكن يصير
وقت انك حتى لو ما اقتنعت او اقنعت الاخر
برايك فتعرفوا على وجهه نظرك بشكل او
بصوره افضل وسط هذه يعني المطالبات
والدعايه والنقاش الحضاري ماسك ما فوت
فرصه يتريق كمان ففي تغريده ثانيه سنبدا
كيف ممكن سي ان ان تتناول تغريدته طبعا من
اكبر المنتقدين
لماسكوه لتويتر واللي خايفين على حريه
التعبير منه تغريده ماسك تخيلت عنوان مقال
لسيلان ماسك يمكن ان يهدد حريه التعبير
على تويتر عبر السماح للجميع بالتعبير
حرفيا ومع العنوان حطوا صوره لمذيعه مركب
عليها صوره فيها رده فعله في حاله زي كده
طبعا ميلان رسول في الصوره يعني ينفع
استكر واتساب ممتاز يعني طيب نيجي عاد لي
موضوع ثاني بينافس على اكبر اهتمامات
مستخدمين تويتر وهو ملف عدد الحروف في
التغريده واللي كمان ماسك فتحه امس
للتذكير تويتر لما بدا كان عدد حروف
التغريده 140 بعدين من كم سنه زادوها ل
280 حرف والناس هلالتهم انبسطت بالزياده
وفي طالب بزياده كمان لكن كمان في معارض
ضد الموضوع
مختصر
اللي خايفين مخاوفهم على المنصه وفي اكثر
من تغريده كشف انه من خططه زياده عدد
الحروف في تغريده قال انه هتكون 420 حرف
وفي وحده ثانيه قال لنا هتوصل الممكن للف
[موسيقى]